a bordo de este avión está danny fence y
el periodista estadounidense acaba de
pasar seis meses en una cárcel de
mianmar a su llegada al aeropuerto de
doha una ambulancia le esperaba en la
pista visiblemente más delgado quiso
tranquilizar sobre las condiciones de su
detención
usted ha sido maltratado
le arrestaron y me mantuvieron en
cautiverio sin ninguna razón así que
supongo que sí es una forma de abuso
pero físicamente estaba sano no me
hicieron pasar hambre ni me golpearon la
liberación se produce en vísperas de un
juicio que podría haberle costado caro
al periodista ya fue condenado a 11 años
de prisión por incitación a la
disidencia y asociación ilícita debía
comparecer ante un tribunal el martes
acusado de terrorismo y sedición y esta
vez se enfrentaba a la cadena perpetua
me siento bien físicamente son las
mismas privaciones que conlleva a
cualquier forma de encarcelamiento te
vuelves un poco loco y cuanto más tiempo
pasan más temes que nunca vaya a
terminar eso es lo que más me preocupaba
quedarme en esa situación pero las
negociaciones dirigidas el ex
diplomático estadounidense bill
richardson con el régimen birmano dieron
sus frutos
creo que lo que marcó la diferencia
fueron mis esfuerzos para trabajar con
el gobierno en mi armar la asistencia
humanitaria en las vacunas eso marcó la
diferencia
danny fenster finalmente indultado y
apunto de reunirse con su familia en
eeuu no se olvida de sus ex compañeros
de prisión el periodista reclamó la
liberación de los presos políticos en
myanmar